steve i have to tell you i'm so excited
to be talking with you and
wendy you have called wendy your
favorite creature on the planet hello
gorgeous oh my gosh she's so beautiful
how has wendy changed your life
because she changed my life i mean
she's it just improved it
and and uh
it
yes it's just massively improved my life
i think she's
she's introduced me to a love that
that i i perhaps
may never have known was possible
it's so wild dogs and and and just pets
have this way of opening up a part of
our hearts that we didn't even know
needed to be opened
right
i know i remember when i
i remember when i got my first dog after
getting clean and sober
i just loved him so much his name was
walter
and i felt like it was a similar
experience to when i got my first cell
phone i thought oh my god how did i ever
live without this
ah it's true
the reality is that walter was a jerk
you know i mean like
bless him and rest his soul but he bit
everybody absolutely bit everybody
it was uh like my karmic retribution for
all of my bad behavior
after years of spiritual growth i think
wendy is my reward for having uh
improved myself
oh my gosh i love that you're seeing it
that way because i believe in that and i
think that that's true because the
rescue story is so wild you go to peru
you find wendy and then she stays by
your side
after that right
right and at that time in my life when i
went to peru for that mountain climbing
expedition i felt particularly
plugged in
to the universe like uh
you know i was
really
active with a meditation practice i was
very uh mindful about um
clearing away the wreckage of my past
and i really feel that wendy was the
physical manifestation of
spiritual
things that i was striving for
you make this wonderful rescue video
where you detail this journey of finding
wendy and and of course her coming home
with you what is your favorite part
about your rescue story with her
well
being such an attention [ __ ] the fact
that the video i made about bringing
wendy home from peru
got over 100 million views on facebook
would have to be my favorite thing but
it's also very bittersweet because
uh
i'm excited that that's the most viewed
video i've ever put on the internet but
at the same time it's a real kick in the
nuts to have gone to the links that i've
gone to for years
learned that i couldn't ever do anything
better than rescue a damn dog
this is your calling this is what you
were supposed to do
right
i love that right i mean it's uh it just
it
it speaks to the power of dogs yeah
definitely and what's so great is
obviously you know you've said that
wendy has made
your life better i know that she has
become a licensed therapy dog and you
take her to hospitals to visit children
what's it like knowing that you get to
make a difference in those kids lives
um i mean it uh
it's certainly
it's but certainly fun i got wendy a
little um
remote controlled ferrari which is made
for little kids so that she can drive
through kids hospitals
and um
it it's pretty pretty awesome
um because uh
there's no doubt that that's really
awesome but candidly her toy ferrari
broke
after the first visit
so uh
so so we went we went back and it was
just wendy no ferrari
i love that um also wendy has some
pretty awesome outfits i've noticed is
that fun for you i've seen you guys wear
some matching outfits
i'm impressed super fun yeah
it's super fun she uh she definitely
loves to dress up yeah
okay so you know how dogs can sense
sometimes if you're in a good mood or a
bad mood i know that my dog definitely
she'll sit next to me for longer if she
knows i'm upset about anything
you do some pretty incredible stunts for
jackass like does your dog ever
you know get nervous or or she can sense
that you're either putting yourself in
danger
or because you do some pretty pretty
wild stunts
yeah
there was a time where it seemed very
evident that wendy was coming to
help me when i got hurt
um i jumped up the roof of my house into
a hot tub
and uh
i really really shouldn't have done that
because my butt clipped the bench that
you sit on inside
and uh hurt it hurt really bad i crawled
out of the hot tub and i was laying on
the
on the ground in terrible pain
and um the first thing wendy did was
come over
to uh to help me
oh my gosh
there's other times when we've done
stuff in the ocean
and uh that i feel maybe my strongest
bond with wendy when i get in the ocean
and she's so evidently not okay with it
like she doesn't want to get in the
water but she's like she
she wants to but she
she did it uh to see her
care for me and worry about me being in
the water is really really cool
and this was an instant bond like the
minute you saw her you knew
well
um
the uh
one of the first things i saw wendy do
was eat poop out of a diaper
no you were like that's for me that dog
is for me yeah
so the answer to the question is yes it
was an instant bond and i knew she was
the one right away
see i haven't heard that story yet
that's a good one yeah you know i i i
didn't include that part of the footage
in the video i i uh there's definitely
video of her eating poop out of a diaper
and um
maybe i should have put it in there
that uh that might have slowed down the
viewership on facebook but
no it's nothing i enjoyed that story for
me thank you yeah that's awesome
that's an exclusive for et canada thank
you we appreciate that you know it's
been cool seeing you on social media
you've obviously become a big supporter
and advocate for rescuing dogs and you
know you've worked with charities uh for
like stand up for pits
do you find that since
you found wendy that you want to do more
advocacy
um
well i wanted to do advocacy for animals
way before i found wendy um
yeah for sure
my fiance and i are both super into
animals and and we've
come up with this plan to buy a big
property and open up an animal sanctuary
um and we we just love that idea and as
we uh
work toward that goal we've been loading
up our house with animals
we built a little barn
at the side of our house yeah for for
our goats to sleep in at night
we've got three goats in the hollywood
hills
that's important we've also got yeah
we've got three cats and three dogs
so yeah that's our total so far i love
that okay so you have three dogs now did
you get another dog after wendy and it
didn't go so well at the beginning
well yeah that was actually
when we had four dogs we've since lost
walter
walter finally made it to doggy heaven
yeah and um
so we had four dogs and we went to costa
rica to get a fifth dog and that was a
little bit of a misfire because we had
uh
um the the new dog we got in costa rica
attacked
one of our other dogs and yeah and it
was so we
we managed to re-home that dog okay good
okay i was gonna say like how are things
now so now you have three dollars
everyone gets along
everybody gets along great
and um yeah the the the dogwoods the
which we had the misfire with from costa
rica now lives on a farm in oregon
and we get
photo and video updates pretty regularly
and it's great to see
that's amazing it's worth mentioning too
that we
are
really dead set on
buying our property for our animal
sanctuary in canada
really how come in canada
well because i'm pessimistic about the
future of america and um i have a
canadian passport
so um
i consider my canadian passport to be my
most prized possession
it was uh america
america's tough and um
you know i describe it as like a frog in
a boiling pot situation where it just
gets hotter and hotter you don't even
realize it until it's boiling and you
know i look at what's going on in
america now or carjackings are the norm
you know like these like
organized like lootings and you know
like
everything uh with all the crime and the
homelessness and and just tough
situations getting very dire i feel like
and um
and and with the economy and all the
debt and you know
i just think america is a little bit
headed in a tough direction and to be
able to go to canada because i'm
canadian is something that uh
something i'm really grateful for having
as an option
well we would love to have you here that
would be amazing i'd love to interview
you you know again if when that happens
that would be exciting so you know when
you think of your your journey with
wendy do you have any advice or or words
of wisdom for anyone who's looking to
bring a dog into their family
um
that he's looking to bring a dog into
the bed i would say uh you know adopt
don't shop i think that's a very
worthwhile message
i think you find that when you buy
puppies from puppy mills that um not
only are you supporting like a really
pretty terrible industry but you
actually often end up with dogs that are
kind of messed up from inbreeding yeah i
know it's so sad
so i think just like
you know
everything about
uh
you know everything about puppy breeding
is pretty
pretty bad and i think you're going to
get a better dog if
you rescue them
yeah
you've said how uh just to wrap things
up you've said how you know wendy's made
your life better what is your favorite
thing about her
um my favorite thing about wendy is in
the mornings she's very snuggly in the
mornings
ah i lure her onto bed at night with
treats so that uh
so that i can snuggle with her but she
does what i call the diamond dash
she comes
takes the treat and then she she dips
out but uh in the morning she's very
amenable to my neediness oh that
snuggles with me a lot so
yeah i i treasure my mornings with wendy
oh my god i love that my dog doesn't
like eating treats in front of me she
has to go to another room to eat it
oh no not wendy she's fine with it no
that's good
that's awesome she needs saving tips